today is the day you learn twin motion
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
talmich I'm a redstone architect here in
Western Australia and today I'm going to
be showing you the complete Suite of
twin motion 2023 and explaining
everything in intricate detail so you as
an absolute beginner can be a pro by the
end of this video now obviously if
you're going to be using twin motion
you're going to need to have twin motion
installed so go ahead jump on Google
type in epic games download the epic
games downloader and we're going to be
able to open and download a twin version
so from the home screen there for games
you jump across the top tab where it
says twin motion and simply hit launch
once twin motion 2023 opens up you have
a variety of options to choose from
let's go with the most basic and just
start a new scene what you see in 2023
is the brand new UI now this UI is
arguably somewhat more complicated than
the last one but it does give you a lot
more details so let's break it down the
left hand side is going to be your
working palette all in your materials
your object your lighting is going to be
on this left hand panel if you want to
toggle it on and off down the bottom
right hand side you're going to have
your library panel so you can just
toggle it as you see fit directly next
to that panel you're going to have a
statistics panel that shows you the
operating power of your computer so if
twin motion is crashing continuously
you're probably working your computer
way too hard and you can keep an eye on
this however I don't see much point to
that so I keep that closed at the top we
have another toolbar that is generally
just for movement and orientation most
important one up top is this material
picker and you're probably going to use
that the most out of everything at the
top the rest you can work your way
through with keyboard shortcuts just in
the top right hand corner of the working
screen you have full screen mode and you
also have the eye button the eye button
basically allows you to change time of
day gives you the shortcuts to the speed
settings when you move around with the
camera so numbers one third of six
increase and decrease the speed
according Lee you can take a quick
screenshot if you need to render out you
can go to pedestrian or drone mode and
you can also do VR you have a few
different views and a cross section also
the Navigator down the bottom most of
these items you don't really need to use
throughout your experience only if
you're trying to change some intricate
details now on the right hand side
you're going to see your secondary
Navigator the very top is your scene
Navigator you're able to toggle on and
off any individual scene or any
individual material and object you can
also simply select them from here press
the delete button to remove it
completely command or control Z or Zed
wherever you are around the world lets
you undo that last command just like any
other program you might be using if we
come back to our material picker up the
top and select our favorite little
material down here visible in Twin
motion it's going to show you what that
material is so at the moment that
material showcased in the middle of our
screen is Nightmare marble and you have
full flexibility and control of this
material so we'll talk through this once
and then we'll get into the intricate
detailing of how to actually use twin
motion feel free to skip ahead in this
timeline if you already know all about
the materials and how to adjust them
perfectly to your desired requirements
first of all we have our material up top
and then we have our color selection if
we wanted to adjust the primary
underlying color of the material we can
select the color open up the Color
Picker and then adjust it as we see fit
so let's say we want to make it a deeper
red a deeper purple whatever we wanted
we could change that by simply changing
the Hues of the underlying tones I'm
going to Simply cancel that for now
moving across the Grange Grange
basically introduces a few different
elements of weathering and texturing so
if I press the w a s and D keys to move
forward back left or right we can fly in
closer to this little ball and
experience this in a high quality
texture so let's move ever so close to
this ball if I increase the Grange you
will see some slight texturing and some
slight weathering of the marble now
marble is obviously a very tough
material so there's not going to be too
much weathering but let's say we come
across to our materials go to concrete
simply drag and drop a base concrete on
there and then change the Grange you're
going to see a lot more discoloration a
lot more aging and basically do it on
the product so command Z Z gets this all
the way back to where we look for
lumiosity basically increases the
brightness or dullness of the material
and underlaying object so if we wanted
to make it basically black take away all
the detail would push it down to zero if
we wanted to increase the brightness and
just make it a little bit more Punchy we
can bring it up to 100 you can also tap
on anything to just reduce that simply
down to 50 60 whatever percent you need
if you need to working through more
details you can tap the details button
change the actual texture from something
that you've downloaded off the internet
just simply go open and you can select a
new texture from the UV Maps you have
downloaded you can adjust the saturation
gamma lift and grain all sliders very
simple to use it just depends on what
you're trying to achieve next we've got
our UV category which basically allows
you to rotate the material increase the
scale of the material and also go into
the finer details the stretch it or one
act there's two axises move it spread it
speed it do whatever you need speed is
an interesting one mainly used for
beacons moving Parts water things like
that it lets you adjust the material so
it actually moves in One Direction if
you wanted to create maybe like a
waterfall effect effect of this ball you
could use this as well so now we'll turn
that back down to zero and move on
roughness pretty self-explanatory drag
it up and down increase the smoothness
or roughness zero percent makes it quite
shiny 100 makes it extremely rough
Granite ideally sits somewhere in the
middle bit of a stain protector over the
top metallicness exactly what it says
increase decrease to increase the shine
of the material itself both roughness
and metallic have their own textures so
if you are changing the materials make
sure you go through open up the correct
textures and import them one by one into
these spaces as well we have a few more
categories down the bottom but for a
beginner tutorial there's probably going
a little bit too far the only thing you
might want to look at is X-ray and if
you turn X-ray on it basically just
allows you to see through the object it
isn't too useful for a beginner at all
but it is there as a choice inside
miscellaneous one of my favorite
features is the two-sided object so if
you have an object that is complicated
curves complicated geometry maybe a
gutter or a sink you can simply turn on
two-sided to make sure that texture
covers every single element of it so
two-sided on this will do absolutely
nothing but if you seem to be missing
some textures here and there make sure
you tick two-sided The Sounds down the
bottom become quite critical and quite
important when you're doing 3D videos
and exporting noise from Twin motion
however I don't find too much value in
them because if you're doing a video
You're exporting it into Premiere Pro
and then after that you're actually
adding your Custom Sounds one by one and
there you have it now we've covered all
of the basics and UI of twin motion so
let's actually import a real live
project and start working on it adding
materials textures grass the works I
will make this project available to all
of you I'll simply leave it in the
description down below I'll make it 100
free so you can all experience this and
learn a step by step so feel free to
download that project right now import
it into twin motion and keep going with
this tutorial okay so now that we have
our model imported we're going to start
adding some textures some materials and
enhancing the background and environment
I like to set up the first scene that
way we can understand what we're trying
to articulate the lighting the mood and
everything around it so let's start by
coming across to our HDR environments
selecting Skies personally I like
morning and mid-afternoon I like cloudy
and one of my favorites is the morning
cloudy 16. now obviously there's
hundreds of options here but all you
have to do is download one that you like
drag and drop it onto the sky it will
then create that background in that
texture and change the entire lighting
environment if we make sure we're
selecting Ambience at the top we can
scroll down to our HDR environment and
then adjust as we see fit so at the
moment the sun is coming in from the
left hand side of the screen or I can
adjust the rotation to however I see fit
and more appropriate for this scene so
let's say I like maybe some 24 degree
rotation and then I can adjust the
intensity as well so the intensity is
going to adjust the actual sky it isn't
going to adjust too many other things
but it will change the entire
environment what you want to do is make
sure that sky is approximately the same
intensity as the overall scene itself so
this is quite a bright and vibrant scene
so I'm going to increase that to about
6.35 now Pro tip if you want to replace
this background with an environment that
actually works something realistic off
Google there's one very easy and quick
way you can do it so let's simply jump
across to Google Maps grab your little
man
drop him anywhere in the world wherever
there's a scene then you want to copy
this entire URL so whatever environment
you've selected that you need copy that
URL you're then going to need a program
called street view download 360. I'll
share this in the description down below
as well once you've downloaded and
installed it it's going to look
something like this all you need to do
is paste that URL into the file select
your path destination and change the
resolution as you see fit the higher the
resolution the longer this process is
going to take and the downloader from a
JPEG to a hdri is a little bit slow so I
do like to stick to about the 6000 Mark
and not go too far once you've found
your specific space you can jump across
to convertio which allows you to upload
the jpeg exported from the Street Viewer
so let's drag and drop our Street Viewer
copy and then we can change this to HDR
click OK and click convert download that
into our project so coming back into
twin motion let's say you completed all
of those steps found a site that you
love to converted it to a HDR you can
come to this preview open and select a
new map so from the downloads file I've
selected that map that has downloaded
it's going to load this hdri in the
background and as you can see it's
loaded a real life scenario from a 360
camera in Google Maps now it's messed
with our entire lighting scene and
everything in between so we're going to
readjust our intensity and our rotation
to perfectly align with what we need so
now we've aligned our rotation we want
to come into details and we do not want
to lock our sun with our hdri generally
speaking I would advise locking it
because it really ties that image
together however in this case I just
don't think it is appropriate so now
that we've unlocked our sun and our Sky
rotation we can come back up to our
exposure controls at the very top for
Global lighting come down to details to
adjust as we need to so at the moment I
have exposure compensation turned on and
at -1 if I untick that I could adjust my
exposure completely and freely this is
quite useful in interior shots but for
this specific photo we're going to keep
exposure compensation on and reduce that
back down to minus one what you will
notice as well is this image right now
that we're modeling is a little bit too
warm a little bit too yellow in
comparison to the background so I'm
going to adjust my white balance just a
little bit lower a little bit cooler to
tie that in and make it look like it
actually blends with our environment so
we're making this image significantly
cooler let's go 6000 kelvins should be
approximately right we can tweak that
later now we've moved quite far pretty
quickly and we have a somewhat realistic
environment coming together quite nicely
now it's time to start importing some
textures some overlays some plants and
everything in between to make this
really pop now I like this setup I like
how it's working so what I'm going to do
is fly around a little bit come down to
the bottom UI May media map which I
specifically ignored at the start
because it has everything to do with how
you model and interact what we're going
to do is we're going to firstly open up
our media tab now we've got our Media
mode open we can simply click the plus
button to create our very first image
now our image is set up by default to
the twin motion default settings what we
want to do is come across to our camera
and start messing with our focal lengths
to see what we really like it personally
I like a 35mm focal length I believe it
makes it look a little bit more punched
in a little bit more realistic so that's
why I personally opt for about 35 mil
wherever possible I don't mess around
with the depth field or anything else
because it tends to make life a little
bit too hard so now that we've set up 35
mil we want to come back across to our
image and hit the refresh button that's
going to save those settings we've
adjusted if for whatever reason we move
around adjust it change it don't like
the settings we've done we can simply
double click on our image and it will
come back directly to where we saved it
be cautious once you change these
settings they're automatically applied
it only has to do with the camera angles
and the materials you've highlighted and
selected toggled on and off now coming
across to our render we can either do
real-time path Tracer depending on the
quality of your machine is going to
dictate if these are active or not for
you to make this seem a little bit more
realistic we want to soften these
Shadows so you can see these Shadows are
quite harsh across our building and
there will be as we add more materials
and textures and objects so I like to
increase the shadow depth just over a
thousand to make them nice and soft the
shadow bias can also be increased and
decreased I like to make my scenes a
little bit darker a little bit more
Moody so I do drop the shadow biased
ever so slightly moving across to our
effects this is all personal opinion and
subject to how you like to see your
images I like to drop my saturation down
to about 40 just so it takes away all
those overpowering colors that make it
look like a render I then like to
increase my contrast to about 55 60 to
give it a bit of punch into kick I do
adjust all of this later on in Lightroom
if you do want to do that as well you
can most certainly but this is a very
nice way to get an easy exported image
last but not least we do want to change
our output size on our very first image
that we create that way you don't have
to go through and select each individual
image to change the output size go to
whatever the maximum your computer
allows you to to get the best quality
render so let's go 8K in this instance
to make sure we get the best possible
quality if you're just exporting to get
the idea in the image simply drop it
back down 2K so you're not waiting
forever for this to export however that
is basically all of the settings there
are to set up one of your first media
modes we can use all of these same
skills to come across to the video a
little bit later on but let's start
implementing some beautiful materials to
make it look just that little bit better
so let's dive back to our library at the
top go to materials and start applying
some little bits and pieces first of all
I want this Timber to be black I don't
want it to be gray I simply applied a
white and gray color palette to this
entire model just so you can see a
complete transformation for me
personally I can go to the material
picker and select that material because
it is already a Timber Walnut finish I
can then change my color to a nice black
now obviously this scene is quite dark I
don't want it to be blacked out
completely with no texture so I do need
to adjust it to the scene specifically
and that's exactly the reason why you
want to set up your lighting and your
camera angles first so let's adjust this
to a nice charcoal black somewhere about
here is perfect I'm going to press OK I
do want a little bit of Grange some
aging some weathering on that material I
don't need it to be as bright so I'm
going to take that Lumia down and I'm
going to increase the roughness to about
75 because it is timbered as a natural
material it is meant to be rough coming
back to our material let's go in
materials and start with the glass the
latest version of twin motion 2023 has
had a massive Improvement on all its
materials and glass which is great
because now we have better quality
selections to choose from personally I
like the reflective glass on the actual
glass itself now you'll see this panel
is a little bit different that's because
these windows are actually Louver
windows so they're reflecting at a
completely different angle and they're
reflecting the background of whatever
this house is now a pool in the middle
I've specifically made it a different
glass texture I'm going to make that
clear glass so we can see what's going
on inside our pool we'll come back to
how we can add water into this space and
make it very realistic as we move
forward cutting back to our materials we
want to go to our ground and start
adding some Greenery some nature so
let's go into nature and select one of
our grass textures to apply it to the
surrounds personally I like grass five
because it's a little bit darker a
little bit more Moody and brings that
image together again completely up to
you what images and textures you select
we're going to fly up a little bit and
also see our Planters in here have a
different texture applied so we want to
change that to a nice dirt or mud finish
let's use the generic dirt image let's
make that a little bit darker so it
looks a bit more like mulch rather than
just plain dirt our driveway is
definitely a man-made object and not a
natural object so we're going to come
back into our palette and select
something a little bit different let's
say we want an old school Cobblestone
driveway to really make this house look
expensive modern and elegant so let's
drag drop that completely changes the
entire environment if I double click on
image one we can see it's changed ever
so slightly I can take my material
picker adjust it increase the lumiosity
to make it a little bit lighter a little
bit brighter and there we go it ties it
back in so beautifully now these bare
concrete retaining walls I do actually
want to keep them as bare concrete
retaining walls but I want a little bit
of a nicer bare concrete so let's come
back into our concrete drag it back over
increase to make it a nice bright white
give a little bit of Grange because it
is going to age it is going to weather
nothing stays perfect and pristine
forever next we want to come back into
our materials take our brushed aluminum
drop it onto our window frames adjust
the color down to a nice black Monument
deep dark tone press OK and slowly we're
starting to get an image forming now we
want to fly up a little bit to see what
else is going on we can see our pool
tiles a little bit boring a little bit
gray and they need to have that blue
tinge to really bring out that water so
let's come back to our materials find
some beautiful tiles scroll down to the
bottom Mosaic blue there we go we have
blue tiles is sitting inside our
beautiful pool now obviously this pool
is empty we want to make it something
special we want to add some water to it
so let's come back to our library
palette let's go to objects let's go to
water and select our water Cube and we
can now start adjusting it to fit this
pool so now that we've selected this
watercube we can press the tab button to
open up different settings so tabbing
through them first of all we have our
movement in all directions we have our
adjustment and scale tool and we have
our movement in just one single
Direction so I'm going to tab across
until I have my adjustment tool if you
don't want to press tab continuously
these options do change up the top here
in this Navigator so if you simply are
on the wrong one you can just tap across
to where you need to be now we're going
to select each one of these little nodes
to adjust this pool to exactly the right
length as we need it and there we go
we've adjusted our pool to the right
depth to the right size and scale and if
we want to change our appearance of our
pool let's say we want a darker or more
blue tinge we can simply select that
Cube and change our appearances here now
our image is starting to come together
but it needs some life it needs some
character at the moment it's just an
architectural piece in the middle of
nowhere so let's come back out to our
library let's go to vegetation let's go
to trees first of all and let's input a
few trees on the side left and right so
we can actually get them let's select
any tree that you personally like and
let's drop in a tree on the left and
let's drop another Tree in on the right
so now if we select our image one we'll
see this trees are in our scene but not
perfectly aligned so we first select our
left tree let's push our left tree back
ever so slightly double click
I like the placement of that tree I'm
happy with the placement of that tree
select our right tree come back across
using our Mouse right clicking to pan
around obviously we can rotate this tree
to how we need it to be let's say we
just want it ever so slightly hovering
over this building if we select this
tree it'll change some of our settings
on the right hand side we can increase
the age Let It Grow or let it shrink as
well and we can also change the seasons
individually and independently so if we
wanted that tree to look like it was in
the middle of Autumn we could simply do
that however I keep it on auto so if you
adjust the weather all the trees adjust
at the same time we can continue adding
all sorts of shrubs into this
environment by simply coming back to our
vegetation selecting shrubs let's add
one or two base bushes
around our trees so it looks like
they're just growing out of nature we
can see that starting to blend in with
environment now which is beautiful the
grass at the moment is very 2D very
basic there is two ways we can go around
adding beautiful three detection grass
in Twin motion we come across to our
populate panel down the very bottom we
select foliage we can either paint it on
with a paintbrush and simply go through
every little bit or we can do our
scatter tool so our scatter tool very
simple to use back to vegetation grass
drag and drop any of the grass that you
see fit select that material select the
scatter tool and then click a couple
times on the green patch so as you'll
see It'll create 3D textured grass very
quickly and you can adjust the scale of
it as you require if you want to fine
tune it a little bit because it's
growing over our curb you could select
the Eraser tool renew use our diameter
down to 0.5 of a meter and then a raise
just the little bits that are overgrown
and you don't need to see them if we
want to continue add a few more
background trees let's grab this
Australian pine drop it in the
background maybe over here and then
another one just over here coming back
into our scene we can see them blending
in so I don't want that one there I'm
going to move it ever so slightly across
so we can still see this tree growing
moving in the background and I'm going
to adjust the one on the other side as
well it's kind of how it hide a very
blurry 3D house from Google Now the
difference between a very basic render
and a very nice professional render is
the environment the scenery and the Suns
and shadows you can see we've set our
Suns and shadows to come from the left
hand side of our screen over our
building which means anything on the
other side of the street will also cast
The Shadow onto the street at the moment
the stream is boring Bland and just a
big concrete slab so let's fly back
around select our Australian pine tree
and let's add a couple of these pine
trees into our scene we also want to add
maybe a couple smaller trees in between
to cast some different shadows so double
clicking now you can see that street has
become a little bit more extent situated
a little bit more beautiful if we come
back to our Ambience go to our
environment we can then offset our
location to adjust how those trees fall
on the street and how those Shadows are
cast so I like them sweeping across the
entire Street it makes it look quite
nice quite beautiful now instead of
going into our materials palette we're
going to select Mega scans Mega scans is
a free import into twin motion that has
so many more features so many more
surfaces so let's select surfaces go
down to Asphalt let's go into fine and
pick one asphalt that we see fit for
this project I'm simply going to select
fine asphalt let it download and drag
and drop it onto our road now that road
is a beautiful dark black asphalt you
can see some textures rotating around
the wrong way so we're going to rotate
that asphalt 90 degrees we're going to
definitely increase the Grange of this
because roads are dirty filthy and have
lots of weathering decrease a lumiosity
and increase our roughness now that we
have our pitch black brand new asphalt
road we're gonna come back to our
library go to our objects select details
now I'm simply going to use the dash
markings tool in the middle of our scene
perfectly in the middle there and then
I'm going to use a line marking right at
the edge of this curb hover over the
Green Arrow to allow it to move left and
right hold the shift button drag it
across to where we see fit let go and it
will allow us to copy it if we want to
copy the incidents which basically means
if we'd ever change any of the materials
or selections of that one it'll change
all of them or it allows us to copy it
directly if we copy it we can change
each individual material individually so
for this it's an instance for me I don't
see any changes required I want to have
at least three of them copy into so it
comes across the whole street press OK
escape and you'll see that beautiful
white line created along the entire Road
itself we want to add a little bit more
texture and depth to the scene we can
add a little sewer in the bottom right
to left corner as if we were standing on
the other curb we can then continue to
scroll down add a little puddle next to
that and there we go we've got some
texture in the foreground some texture
in the background it's all starting to
slowly come together now this building
needs a lot more to actually give it
some punch and some kick these Planters
on the left hand side were designed to
be just that Planters with cascading
plants and a beautiful feature in the
middle here however at the moment
they're just being boxes of dirt so what
we need to do is actually populate them
with some beautiful plants there are
four ways we can actually populate this
right here first of all we can go to
vegetation and select trees and shrubs
individually secondly we can go into
Mega scans go to 3D plants and again
populate that individually we can go to
sketchfab and basically access an online
public resource of libraries textures
materials plants
or last but not least we can actually
import directly an fbx model from any
supplier so let's go ahead and actually
import an fbx model as a feature into
this project so we want to come down to
the bottom import doc click the import
button and open up a geometry I've
downloaded some garage trees in the past
which is a very Australian plant that we
can use in this project so we have a
series of different grass trees simply
select the fbx Press open and allow it
to import when prompted we want to use
the imported materials not the scene
materials the imported materials of an
fbx file are those high quality textures
specific to this so make sure you select
imported materials press ok now when
importing an fbx IT throws it to random
zero zero point new project so come
across to your Navigator select that
plant find where it has dropped it in
make sure you hover over the large ball
in the middle drag it in to your
environment so let's say we want this
one approximately here and then I'm
going to repeat this process to add all
of those other grass trees in so we have
our grass trees imported we can repeat
this process and basically align the
grass trees where we actually want them
to go so let's just drag and drop a few
garage trees wherever we really see fits
this grass tree looks to be the biggest
one so it's definitely going to be my
feature Grass Tree I'll move this other
one back and I can duplicate it the same
way as before select any one of these
material objects hold shift duplicate
the instance and repeat this step a few
more times to basically populate my
grass trees in between the entire space
and now we have a beautiful variety of
grass trees growing in our Planters we
also want to populate this with a few
little Vines the little creepers some
bits and pieces from our Bush selection
so I'm going to go through that quickly
populate that and then come back now
inside these scans in our 3d plant
selection we also have some climbers to
choose from so if we want to actually
grab some climbers around this retaining
wall we can download a few of these
options to actually be able to implement
some beautiful climbers now we've
populated our climbers we've populated
our plants I'll take a quick moment here
just to refer you to the description box
down below there is a series of great
leaks and resources including a free
Discord chat which basically hosts a
community of Architects designers and
students in the architectural profession
all around the world looking to grow and
enhance their skill use so if you
believe you fit into this community feel
free to hit that Discord link and join
it 100 for free we can start working on
the lighting and the detail inside of
this project so let's come back out into
our library let's fly into our building
and select our lights I like to use the
area light because it floods the entire
space first of all so let's drag and
drop an area light into this space fly
around make sure it is perfectly aligned
to our first space and repeat that a few
times across so now internally that is
flooded with natural light and it's
starting to Glow repeat that same step
in this bedroom over here and then we
want to add some actual 3D lights so
let's go back to sketchfab let's try
type in down light and see what we can
find dragging and dropping that into our
actual project allowing it to create
tapping the F key on your keyboard to
find it we'll see it is incredibly large
so let's make that 0.1 and 0.1 again tap
the F key to find it once again it is
still way too big so 0.1 and now we're
starting to actually get it to the
appropriate size that it needs to be we
can Tab and readjust it to suit it there
we go now we have our first little down
light sitting on our concrete we just
want to adjust it perfectly to where it
needs to sit once we place our first
down light we can copy and paste these
across quite easily so we have our first
down light I'm going to adjust it to
somewhere approximately over here in the
project then I'm going to come out of my
sketch Fab make sure I go back to my
materials Library select materials
scroll to the bottom select Neons and
drag and drop neon number two onto that
down light now that down light will have
its own little glow and look very
realistic I also want to copy and paste
the material from the window frame onto
the actual down light so we have a black
fixture that is very noticeable and very
visible finally I want to come across to
my library go to my lights Spotlight and
drop one Spotlight directly above that
light so if I pan out a little bit
select my Spotlight you can see it is
quite bright quite overpowering so I'm
going to reduce the lumience from 300 to
100 so it isn't too bright select my
download light and my Spotlight hold
shift drag it across
let's say one copy every three meters
okay then select both of those down
lights and fly out of my building I'm
then going to replicate it every two
meters for approximately five meters
press OK and now you'll see we have
spotlights throughout our entire
building itself I want to do the same
procedure in this little space over here
because that's all we can see from our
first image there we go if we come back
to our image one we'll see our down
lights inside our building it started to
look a little bit more real it's
starting to look a bit realistic I do
also want to add two textured LED strips
in to this soffit of the building so I
can go ahead and try and find an LED
strip perfect for that or I come into
Library go to primitive objects select
my box drag and drop the Box in
scale it to approximately the size I
need
add the neon texture to it just like we
did for those down lights and then drag
it and drop it into our soffit and scale
it appropriately
so I don't need that to be perfect but I
do need it to be quite good so I'm going
to scale it about there align it to the
center copy and paste it to the other
side make sure I select copy this time
instead of instance so I'm not messing
with all of the shapes that I've created
at once
readjust and copy once more to get the
front LED working and there we have it
now we have our internal lighting we
have our down lights we have our neon
strip lights and we have our external
scene pretty much set up ready to go now
we can continue this entire process for
the furniture for the characters the
people we can add some life some actual
Vibrance to this scene we can also do
that for our vehicles so if we come back
out to sketchfab go to our cars and
vehicles you see I've downloaded a few
in the past so let's simply drag and
drop
this Ferrari into our driveway now all
we have to do is align the Ferrari
correctly and move it to where we need
so now we have a beautiful Ferrari
sitting in our driveway perfectly
aligned with this beautiful house and
our first scene completely finished if
we wanted to convert this image into a
video all we simply do is come across to
the video tab at the top and pan across
to where we want our first scene to
start for this theater video so say we
want our 3D video to start from here
click the plus button then fly around to
our second scene where you want that
video to end let's say we want it to end
about here
select the plus button once again and
double click on the start press the play
button you will see that video start to
form if we press pause we can then
adjust our video playback speed let's
say that was a little bit too fast for
us let's tap 30 seconds double click on
start press play again it'll be a nice
smooth elegant motion if you want the
camera to continue moving from this one
scene you simply press the add button
continuously however if you want to make
a jump cut to a different space so let's
say we wanted to finish our jump cut in
front of this pool we'll start it right
here we're then going to press a brand
new plus button so it starts a whole
second part of that fly out drop down to
about there press our plus button and
then if we play from about there you'll
see that instead of moving that camera
up to the pool it'll just jump straight
up to that next scene now you've done
all this hard work everything's finished
everything's tidied up you're going to
need to export these images and these
videos so how do we do that it is very
easy to export twin motion simply come
across the export button press the plus
on the image select the images you want
to export select the Plus on the video
select the video you want to export and
scroll to the bottom and Press Start
export anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the content if you did
there's more twin motion tutorials just
for the side of me if you love the
content make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below but like I
mentioned that's all from me so I'll see
you next Monday